hi there and welcome to our second video
in the series on sre and devops my name
is Seth and I'm a developer advocate at
Google focused on infrastructure and
operations and hi I'm Liz a site
reliability engineer or essary at Google
where I teach Google cloud customers how
to build and operate reliable services
so have you ever run into the problem
where you're trying to talk about
reliability and availability and you get
so many different definitions that makes
your head want to spin it happens all
the time and even worse have you ever
run into the situation where the
developers are trying to push out new
features and they're breaking things
more and more and they just won't listen
it's like you're in my head have we
worked together before my team is
constantly putting out fires many of
which end up being bugs in the
developers code but when we try to push
back on the product teams to focus on
reliability they don't agree that
reliability is an issue it's like a
classic DevOps problem do you have any
recommendations yeah this is a really
common problem in the relationship
between product developers and operators
and it's a problem that Google was
really worried about in the early 2000s
when we were first building out Google
web search and this is when we started
defining the SOA discipline and its
really been a work in progress that
we're improving on since Wow Google had
these same problems in the early 2000s I
had no idea but I still don't understand
how can Sree help solve this apparently
very common problem so Esper each tries
to solve this problem in three different
ways first of all we try to define what
availability is secondly we try to
define what an appropriate level of
availability is and third we get
everyone on the same page about what we
were going to do if we fail to live up
to those standards and we try to
communicate this across all the
organization from product developers to
s eries and all the way from individual
contributors all the way up to
vice-presidents that way we have a
shared sense of responsibility for the
service and of what we're going to do if
it we need to slow down and we do that
by defining service level objectives in
collaboration with the product owners
and by agreeing on these metrics in
advance we make sure that there's less
of a chance of confusion and conflict in
the future okay so an SLO is just an
agreement among stakeholders about
how reliable a service should be but
shouldn't services just always be 100%
reliable so the problem is that the cost
and the technical complexity of making
services more reliable gets higher and
higher the closer to 100% you try to get
it winds up being the case that every
application has a unique set of
requirements that dictate how reliable
doesn't have to be before customers no
longer notice the difference and that
means that we can make sure that we have
enough room for error in enough room to
roll out features reliably I see we
should probably do another video where
we talk about why 100% availability
isn't a real target okay Liz I'm ready
I've decided that I want my service to
be 99.9% reliable so where do I get
started do I use vim Emacs Nano what do
I do
so I'm a nano user but first you really
have to define what availability is in
addition to defining how available you
want to be we need to make sure that we
understand what availability is in the
context our service and that we have
clear numerical indicators for defining
that availability and the way that we go
about doing that is by defining not just
service level objectives but service
level indicators or SL eyes so SL eyes
are most often metrics over time such as
request latency the throughput of
requests per second in a case of a batch
system or failures per total number of
requests they're usually aggregated over
time and we typically apply a function
like a percentile like in 99th
percentile or a median and that way we
can get you a concrete threshold which
we can define to say is a single number
good or bad so for instance a good
service level indicator might be saying
is a 99th percentile latency of requests
received in the past 5 minutes less than
300 milliseconds or alternatively
another service level indicator might be
is the ratio of errors to total requests
received in the past 5 minutes less than
1% ok thank you for explaining that it's
much clearer now but how does that SLI
become an SLO so if you think that's
your calculus lesson Seth I know this
may have been a while ago when you have
a service level indicator it says at any
moment in time whether the service was
available or whether it was down so what
we need to do is meet at all of it up or
integrate it over a long
a period of time like a year in your
example of 99.9% over a year to see is
the total amount of downtime that we've
had more or less than than nine hours
that you were worried about but you
should always beat your SLO right No so
the thing is that SLO czar both upper
and lower bounds so this is for two
reasons first of all the fact is that if
you tried to run your service much more
reliable than it needs to be you're
slowing down the release of features
that you might want to get out that
would make your customers happier than
having a extra femtosecond of uptime and
then secondly it's an expectation that
you're sending for your users that if
you suddenly start breaking a lot more
often than they're used to because you
start running exactly at your SLO or
rather than doing much better than your
SLO then your users will be unhappily
surprised if they're trying to build
other services on top of yours okay so
this is this is all starting to make a
little bit of sense now but what is an
SLA then there's so many SL letter
things and I remember in a previous job
I signed an SLA something what did I do
so to spell it out first a SLA is a
service level agreement and what it does
it's it says here's what I am going to
do if I don't meet the level of
reliability that is expected it's more
of a kind of commercial agreement that
describes what remediation you're going
to take if your service is out of spec
according to the contract I see so the
SLA is like a business agreement
associated with an SLO so they're
exactly the same right not quite because
you really want to make your SLA more
lenient than your SLO so you get early
warning before you have to do things
like filled angry phone calls from
customers or have to pay them lots of
money for failing to deliver the
services promised we rarely work with
SLA s assessories and instead we focus
on meeting our SL O's with the
understanding that sales teams and
business teams will think more about the
SLA as they build on top of our SL O's I
see so SLA is described the set of
services and availability promises that
a provider is willing to make to a
customer and then the ramifications
associated with failing to deliver on
those promises those ramifications might
be things like money back or free
credits
failing to deliver the service
availability yes that's exactly correct
so to summarize SL is our service level
indicators or metrics overtime which
inform about the health of a service SLO
s our service level objectives which are
greet upon bounds for how often those
slis must be met and finally SLA s our
business level agreements which define
the service availability for a customer
and the penalty is for failing to
deliver that availability exactly so
SLIC
SLO s and SLA s hearken very much the
DevOps principle that measurement is
critical and that the easiest way to
break down the organizational barriers
is to have common language about what it
means to be available and we've give
with SLI is a very well defined
numerical measurement for what that is
and with VI Solo's we collaborate
between the product owners and the
assessories in order to make sure that
the service is running at an appropriate
level of reliability for customers it's
a lot clearer to me now why we say class
s re implements DevOps awesome thanks
Liz and thank you for watching be sure
to check out the description below for
more information and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and stay tuned
for our next video where we discuss risk
and error budgets